nos encontramos en la sede del
excongreso nacional y también en esta
jornada se escuchan manifestaciones A
los alrededores estas serían algunas de
las similitudes de un proceso
constitucional muy diferente a la
anterior impartimos por ejemplo por el
número de miembros son 50 los consejeros
constitucionales uno de ellos
representante de las comunidades
indígenas frente a los 155 miembros del
proceso anterior Donde había 17 escaños
reservados a los pueblos indígenas
además la jornada van a recibir un
anteproyecto de texto constitucional
elaborado por una comisión de expertos
de 24 miembros 12 de ellos elegidos por
la cámara de diputados y 12 del senado y
habrá unas 12 bases constitucionales en
las que se tienen que regir esta este
consejo constitucional no es la carta
blanca de la que partía el proceso
anterior además como señalabas en la
ceremonia están presentes los tres
representantes de los poderes del Estado
algo que no ocurría en el proceso
en el que también había un intento más
de que el pueblo estuviera representado
de esta forma se inicia este consejo
constitucional este miércoles aquí en
Santiago